Donald Trump's Attorney General William
bar is expected to release a very
heavily redacted version of the Moller
report to Congress and to the public
tomorrow Thursday morning according to
Justice Department spokeswoman Kari ku
Peck and this is going to be the 400
page Moeller report but of course with
significant redactions blacked out we
don't really know right now what exactly
we're going to get and I want to remind
you that the standard that Donald Trump
and the people around him claimed that
was met with by the Moller report is
total exoneration period he went on a
national tour the exoneration tour no
ifs ands or buts total and complete
exoneration but any sort of sensible
person knows that this isn't very likely
Barr actually quoted Robert Muller as
being unable to exonerate Donald Trump
on the charge of obstruction and more
importantly there's a new report from
NBC News that White House officials are
genuinely concerned about the release of
this report because they're worried
Trump is going to see the report and go
absolutely bonkers for two different
reasons check out this excerpt from an
NBC News article from yesterday quote
some of the more than dozen current and
former White House officials who
cooperated with Special Counsel Robert
Muller are worried that the version of
his report expected to be made public on
Thursday will expose them as the source
of damaging information about President
Donald Trump according to multiple
witnesses in the investigation so
there's two things that might set Trump
completely on fire based on what we're
going to get tomorrow maybe we don't
know yet number one as NBC News is
reporting there were people who work for
Trump who were asked to come in and talk
to molars investigators and many of them
did and they're worried that if Trump
finds out that they were the people who
talked to Muller that he's going to go
absolutely bonkers on them and go into
one of his unhinged rages that we know a
lot about the other reason that the
report might send Trump into a tizzy
over which advisors are worried is that
if the report doesn't actually fully
exonerate Donald Trump which is of
course very
hard to believe that it does given the
the limited information we have about it
right now
that could make Trump go absolutely and
completely off the rails and I think the
important thing to remember about the
people that work for Trump who spoke to
Robert Muller Pat is that these aren't
leakers Trump has a problem with
leaguers in the White House and we've
talked about it but what we're talking
about here is robert muller asked to
speak to someone and they go and they
tell the truth to federal officials
these aren't whistleblowers or leakers
these are people participating in an
investigation and Trump might go nuts on
them of course and tomorrow I think is
going to be a crazy day
we know that loyalty is the most
important thing to Trump and I think
that after the Moller report is released
we could see him start to pardon people
like he could decide that he's gonna
pardon Mike Flynn and Paul Manafort and
Roger stone but not just pardons are we
gonna get we're also maybe going to get
some firings as a result of this yeah
and the funny thing about loyalty which
you mentioned the most important thing
for Trump from other people towards him
is loyalty
Trump has no loyalty to people around
him right we know that in the most
likely scenario is that anyone who Trump
sees as having quote helped the probe by
which what we really mean is federal
investigators wanted to talk to them and
they said okay I'll go talk to you and
I'm not going to lie they may well be
thrown under the bus by Trump
immediately and firings are certainly on
the table the other really strange thing
here is that Donald Trump's lawyers are
reportedly planning a 50-page counter
report for when the Moller report comes
out if the Moller report totally
exonerates you the way you claim why
would you need to counter it with your
own 50 page report doesn't really make
any sense and the thing I was thinking
about this morning when I was reading
about this in preparing for the show
there's very little chance that Trump's
actually going to read the four hundred
page report we know that he doesn't read
so imagine if the people around Trump
who don't want to get fired or or suffer
the wrath of Trump simply don't tell
them what's actually in the report that
we know is a theme of this
administration where Trump the people
around Trump in a number of different
ways propagandize the real world
to trump to kind of keep him placated we
know about the propaganda a propaganda
o'clock file that takes place twice a
day where a file is brought to Donald
Trump of prominent people who tweeted
nice things about him or pictures where
he looked strong and alpha in news media
often Fox News in that same way that
Trump is placated by people around him
they may even shield him from the full
contents of the report and we know he's
not gonna sit down and read 400 pages he
can't even read a two-page presidential
daily intelligence briefing so that's a
question Fox News I'm guessing won't
cover the really incriminating passages
of the report if any are left unredacted
we don't know yet so Trump will will be
very effectively shielded from it in all
likelihood and as far as the redactions
themselves go my guess is that what we
get tomorrow is going to be so heavily
redacted that it will understandably not
satisfy House Democrats who will very
likely end up having to subpoena the
full report and then the legal battle
will begin and who knows how long that's
going to last so we'll be covering it
the earlier we get this report the
better if it leaks tonight so I have
more time to look at it even better and
we'll be talking about it later on this
week let me know what you're expecting
from this report how much are you
thinking will be redacted I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on twitter at
david pakman show and we have a lot to
talk about today one of today's sponsors
is privacy comm slash Pakman this is a
free service that I've actually been
using myself for a while now and I love
it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the Internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a
so a company won't be able to charge you
more than you actually want them to and
it protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below